il est désormais interdit à la vente en
france le roundup proulx 360 se produit
à base de glyphosate destinés aux
agriculteurs
pourtant il avait reçu l'autorisation de
l' agence de sécurité sanitaire hans
hess mais le tribunal administratif de
lyon a annulé cette décision mardi
dernier affirmant que le roundup pro 360
et probablement cancérogène pour l'homme
une décision précipitée et mal reçue par
certains viticulteurs du loir et cher
ça va être quand même assez
problématique pour moi pour le moment le
temps de pouvoir s'adapter
surtout qu'on n'a pas de solution jour
d'aujourd'hui en remplacement du
glyphosate
nicolas est seul sur son exploitation
mais en pleine crise ont ils seront deux
à s'attaquer aux mauvaises herbes et
sans glyphosate il faudra embaucher jour
d'aujourd'hui on va pas dire qu'il ya
que le glyphosate mais le glyphosate est
une des solutions pour pour réussir à
détruire le chien dans quoi nous sommes
ici à montlouis-sur-loire et voici les
40 points ha bio de ce viticulteur
depuis 20 ans c'est ici qu'il récolte et
bichonne ses vignes sans glyphosate ne
plus utiliser cet herbicide ses 30% de
coûts supplémentaires sur sa production
mais il l'a fait quand même le pari de
s'orienter vers cette voie et admet que
la filière n'est pas prête à abandonner
ses produits aujourd'hui on a la
recherche est passé à avancer pour s'en
séparer du jour au lendemain il ya
énormément d'efforts de fait
l'ensemble des vignes on finance aussi
cette recherche pour pouvoir la trouver
des solutions que tout le monde puisse
aller vers une viticulture plus propre
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas les
réponses
total et le consommateur elle n'est pas
prêt aussi à payer plus cher les
produits
le ministère relève d'une culture parle
d'une décision isolée qui ne concerne
qu'un seul produit pour l'instant pas
question d'interdire le glyphosate avant